[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
do you really want to go out in a
[ __ ] hospital
you know because you [ __ ] didn't want
to stop eating enough burgers really
right that's what you're [ __ ] telling
me that you want to go out in the
[ __ ] hospital do you really want to
have to pull up your shirt once a
[ __ ] day
and shoot yourself in the [ __ ]
stomach
when you're on the road and whatever you
know
i i saw ralphie may come in here and i
saw the lump on his neck
from where the that that that [ __ ] that
gets what his cortisol was he that big
from eating
no no he was that big from [ __ ] uh
from ice skating you know
he is
so much when did you start doing
comments 2010 what made you get up
what made me do the first time yeah i
was in the mortgage business and
uh
in 2000 knowledge educated uh no dropped
at a community college uh to do percocet
and sell subprime mortgages in long
island which i still believe is the what
i will return to
i believe stand-up is a sabbatical from
my true calling which is to work in a
strip mall
uh and have great lunches serious
lunches
and uh and take percocet and
and and telemarket mortgages in the
tri-state area you look good
that's very sweet that's also untrue but
i appreciate i appreciate you really i
will tell you what you're looking for
so but you know what it is when you're a
big guy it's all about the way the
camera hits you
because when i when i put myself in my
jacket i look okay i stopped looking at
myself in 1990
all right i stopped looking at myself in
19 years yeah i get yeah in the mirror
now at night and i see grandpa from the
monster
and i laugh for five minutes
i'm like all this [ __ ] they're doing
nobody's be doing grandpa right i would
just kill his grandpa yeah you would be
amazing he was r-rated because grandpa
was a nut yeah downstairs mixing
chemicals yeah
some months you're gonna make 800 bucks
and you suck at the [ __ ] up and some you
make eight grand and some months you
make eight grand yeah you suck at the
[ __ ] up right and somewhere and then you
learn how to balance it you learn right
away the first month you make eight
grand you're in a steak house you got a
porterhouse for two [ __ ] yeah you got a
shellfish tower lobster bottle something
you put some blue claw crab on that too
please thank you very much let's get a
couple of gym martinis uh let's do the
cheesecake bring all the appetizers
lobster bisque port and cups we'll drink
it while we eat the steak
and then it's like then you have to then
you realize you have to pay taxes
because sales is the 10.99 they give you
eight grand you didn't make eight grand
by the way you now owe money so i would
get a check and then i would go out and
spend money and then i'd realize oh i
owe money like i owe
4 000 of that goes to the government and
i didn't pay any of it so
that was something too but when i got
into comedy
the only job i could get was in staten
island and it was photocopiers and and
selling office equipment sad because
when you're selling real estate or
mortgages at least somebody around you
has got a lot of money
and you could look at them and be like
well i want to be that i want to be
you know my boss this guy tim who had a
big house in a pool but when you when
you telemarketing photocopied staten
island everybody there is desperate and
they all have that job because it's in
walking distance of their house or they
could take a bus many of them just had
dewey's what do you mean bus half of my
halfway houses right half of them live
in a shelter yeah half of them are
toothless
they're alcoholics yeah half of those
telemarketing house hbo yeah hasn't
developed
a show i pitched for about 12
telemarketers i know six people who are
[ __ ] serious about life and six
people who live day to day day to day
shoot heroin right they [ __ ] they got
hiv
now the first two years i was driving in
to new york city and i did a lot of
black rooms because black rooms would
let you go up you know a lot of the
alternative rooms they were you know
more selective they were [ __ ] and you
couldn't get into clubs but black rooms
would let you go up urban urban shows
and and they liked me i was a big white
guy i was funny
uh and you know and they were really fun
my friends loved
going to these rooms because these guys
were killer i mean we'd see mike epps
you know smokey suarez these guys are
just murderous all my you know my some
of my friends would come with me and
then when i went to the city i started
doing the alternative rooms and you know
girls would get up and open a moleskine
book my friends stopped coming they were
like we've had enough of this i would
never let myself be a [ __ ] tourist
right like never ever
like my wife tried to be when i took it
to new york the first time yeah and i
had to cut the legs off of that [ __ ]
yeah what was she trying to do like just
dumb [ __ ] yeah like [ __ ] that even if
you live in new york you don't go there
right right when you when you grow up in
new york the first year to take you to
the museum of natural history right to
you can't take it no more yeah look at
that [ __ ] whale
and then and then
they take you to [ __ ]
radio city that's true right yeah and
you go to the [ __ ] empire state
building yeah
you know what i don't even want to do it
again yeah
but that was it still remember like
being in the eighth grade and
being in jersey and they took us to
philly
to see like the nutcracker sweet
yeah the nutcracker and betsy ross's
house yeah like you gotta do all that
[ __ ] yeah
i'll never forget that we went somewhere
and the guy said so i think it was betsy
ross's house
he's like do you know what happened here
and one of my buddies like who gives a
[ __ ]
and he just
because those two people yeah like
they're so into it they're so into it
it's so sad and you can just throw them
off there's nothing worse because when i
was doing that job i used to sell a
single more cigars yeah in the 90s
yeah when i became a regular at the
store the biggest job in l.a was selling
cigars on the phone sunset right across
from rock and roll ralph yeah where the
hotel is walk 50 steps that building
there were 20 [ __ ] [ __ ] in
there
10 of us were
you know uh
actors comics yeah you had to be there
at six five in the morning
five or six in the morning but the other
ten
were [ __ ] people who were toothless
yeah degenerates were [ __ ] drinking
while they were [ __ ] five in the
morning who was the better sales
drinking
there was
listen anybody can have a good day
hunger is hunger bubbles hunger yeah i
died the best salesman was hunger [ __ ]
was a woman in the in the copier office
there was a woman named ida
they go either just sets appointments
they said sit next to idiots you train
you sit next to the top producer when
you train
so you sit next to ida and this was the
top
producer at this still and she looked at
me i'll never forget this because this
just puts in perspective how [ __ ]
everybody was she goes i'm doing good
this year and if i do even better i'm
gonna get a car
and i went oh [ __ ]
she's the top she's mount olympus and
she doesn't have a [ __ ] car i said
she doesn't have a car this was the best
part of my week
right was going to weight watches and
[ __ ] going off
like a lady started accepting it like go
off in there because going to weight
watcher meetings
seem boring on paper but they're very
funny because you're going to start
getting frustrated
because you're going to see people that
are you
right people that go
i don't know what happened last week
every one of my meals i eat bananas and
i still gain eight pounds well
you did something wrong yeah yeah if you
ate bananas every meal
and i walked my action points and i
still gained eight pounds yeah you want
to reach over and smack them right
there's people who go and they'll
actually lose six ounces
yeah like they'll say i lost six ounces
the last two weeks oh my god you know
there's people who go and they gain
weight and they'll go
i could do the food but
i need my glass of wine every night and
you're like
are you this [ __ ] so i had no clothes
i had like a suit that didn't fit like
an ill-fitting suit i'm 300 pounds the
suit doesn't fit my guts hanging out
i have like that the shirt that's half
in half out uh i have shoes that are
basically moccasins
that i'm i'm passing off his dress shoes
because i have no [ __ ] money and
these sales because they don't
understand that
uh and and i'm and i'm walking around
walking in hedge funds i'm walking in
the law office they think i'm homeless
they think that the people are like wait
well the secretaries are trying to stop
me i'm like no no i'm trying to sell
your copier uh i sold a few of them like
except just because i'm a fun guy and
i'd walk in and be like who's this
[ __ ] lunatic somebody came up to me
once ago your thing's great you walk in
like a mess
people take notice of you i go it's not
my thing i have no money they go your
thing what you do is good you wear
ridiculous shoes your shirts got bird
[ __ ] on it it's great they go this is
like uh
they go this is like a [ __ ] thing you
know it was a thing they thought it was
a thing they're like yeah this is this
is good you're like a slob it's not a
diet see that's the world so it's a
lifestyle see i did the keto thing for a
while it worked right i did it because i
want you to do something you're able to
do on the road every day that's hard and
that's where we what that yeah that's
what i tell people yeah well i'm gonna
do the carnivore diet okay
so that means you're gonna eat a steak
for the rest of your [ __ ] life three
times a day and a piece of salmon right
that's what you're telling me right well
i'm gonna do
that again
everybody got something
you know if you live at home and you're
janet jackson yeah that diet is going to
work for you right because you have
people's chests
and doing that i'm going to do that
diet
wait do you get the zanies and it's one
in the morning it's true what are you
gonna eat i'm on my third show with a
knife
i mean do you have the almond milk in
chicago right one yeah
yeah they're just punching the [ __ ]
mouth i saw guys like on a tour bus and
they were just
yelling at a tourist on a bus that was
going through times square and now he's
like well that guy can't have a boss
there can't be any background check to
do that job some of these tour guides in
new york they were lunatics these people
you know one woman i swear to god would
just go on and talk about a knee
operation
and the people and they were trying to
learn about the empire state building
she would say she would hear her she'd
go i've had nine operations on the same
foot
people would
and but people would tip her and yeah it
was like it's you know she was an animal
but people felt bad for her
so they ah
so they fill the tip cup up at the end
so i was like oh these people are also
in their own way con artists degenerates
marginalized
figures from society you know some of
them thought they were historians some
of them
they were all full of [ __ ] you know
these guys they barely knew anything i i
was just like i'll go up there and make
my whole goal was like i'll make
everybody laugh
so i would you know pass a building i'd
be like what the [ __ ] going on in
there you know i'm like you know i was
like you know what were you making doing
that 15 an hour
15 an hour but checks so that's bad so i
know so i 40 hour work weeks i never
left with a check over 350.
okay
but cash tips every day
of either no money
when i was lazy and didn't want to give
the tour and a russian woman punched me
in the stomach once
because we were sitting on the thing it
was jet first of all all the russians
are poor they come in january february
they have no [ __ ] money they're
they're poor they come the coldest time
of the year and then what you'd have to
do a tour for one russian couple and the
thing with russians is they're beautiful
blue eyes like huskies but they have no
souls
so when you see because they have 100
years of atheism so they have no salt so
there's no you know so when you look in
their face you see this there's nothing
there
so i just sat on the bus and this
russian woman said to me she goes you
give tor you [ __ ] [ __ ]
i said listen to the automated tour i
said i'm not doing it today you're the
only people on the bus she goes you get
i pay money you give torah you give tor
and i said no you because i could put it
on the automator when i was being lazy
and the automator would be like and the
automated would was supposed to be
hooked up with a gps but it was never
where it should be
so we'd be by central park and they'd be
like you are seeing the 911 memorial and
everybody would look out like where's
911 you know they had no idea because
the gpa these companies don't care
because these buses there's no repeat
business right you just you you you bang
them
bill burt has a great thing where he
talks about the guys who sell tickets to
these buses they're all africans and
haitians and they all have deep machete
scars in their faces
they make eight or nine grand a month
and they send that all back to africa i
think burr you don't want to weigh in on
[ __ ]
friday right now you're gonna go out
thursday night you weigh in in front of
everybody
no you weigh in when you walk in right
you give the chick your card you sign up
for six months right beep you give the
chick your card you it's like it's 19
fat people watching
yeah
that's what i thought it was no that's
what i thought it was
like you got on the scale and
everybody's just staring at you like you
[ __ ] lied to us the computer's a
scale and then she'll type it in and
she'll go you had a good week
and then you buy [ __ ]
uh sugar-free brownies or whatever they
have they always have snacks there that
i take on the road with them they're
good yeah that's all at night when i and
then you learn how to prepare
tim dillon you're going to [ __ ]
chicago this week [ __ ] i know you're
going to eat a beef and sausage sandwich
i don't know it's so bad guess what but
guess what right but give me do me a
favor from monday through wednesday
behalf
eat the six eggs scrambled i don't give
a [ __ ] eat the chicken breast
get a salad listen
these people well if you're gonna eat a
sandwich
you're putting salad that that just shut
the [ __ ] up yeah right i'm sacrificing
everything right you know i mean that's
tomato but he's fat let me put my
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'll take the five
points
because i mean lettuce and tomato onion
it's not like it's not the thing i would
when i nobody wakes up in the morning
and says you know what
i think i'm gonna have three [ __ ]
salads today because i really want yeah
i can't wait to get my taste on i can't
wait to see how that lettuce is taste
right
and then fans of like my podcast and
[ __ ] got to sit on the bus and see what
i used to do and it was hilarious you
know because i would talk about like
human trafficking
and drugs and and you know my roommates
and you know everybody on broadway they
go it must be amazing to be on broadway
i said these people are all one broken
ankle away from living on the street
then you see a college student like a
high school theater group would come
and their faces would go down and say
they don't make any money i said i know
the woman in phantom of the opera she
drinks soup out of a cup and stares at
the rain in the food emporium i said
every day she wants to put a gun in her
mouth i said so let me tell you i said
and if she falls and sprains her ankle
she's going to be living in the street
and she's going to go have to go to the
suburbs and [ __ ] her way to the middle
class and then she's going to have to
work at your school which i thought was
funny and but one of the kids started
crying
but i'm like this is what it is this is
what life is and that was like my tour
and that wasn't for everybody
they told me you're gonna be picked up
on 36th and third every day you gotta
get there so i figured let me get a
hotel close to that i don't want to stay
in jersey you have to come over the ride
right
you know and i made a mistake
i stayed at a high state of the hotel
where all that [ __ ] goes down yeah the
the the the [ __ ] black guy with the
axe selling yeah
where did you do you remember where you
stayed
i'd rather not sell okay
i think i almost gave me a rate they
were nice people but
i had to leave yeah i had to leave yeah
that area
and i would work out of danger fields
and i remember saying that
new york before you go to new york you
have to take a tourism class yeah like
you have to go somewhere
like before you go to new york yeah you
got to do a little you gotta do
something yeah
and i can't even like even chicago is
too big for you right go to let's start
somewhere small and write yourself up
yeah because you cannot be a [ __ ]
idiot
i saw a lot like i made the mistake and
stayed i was there for three weeks
the first hotel
was a cool hotel but a bit too cool with
uncle joey right yeah i hate those
hotels drinking upstairs right no room
service
the breakfast was english you know yeah
i want lamb chops for breakfast i'll let
you know
i want two [ __ ] eggs before i hate
dick in nashville i ate dick in atlanta
i remember waiting all [ __ ] day to do
a guest set at charlotte little did i
know it was black knight right
i walk in there it's [ __ ] little
africa
i walk into the guest spot they look at
me like nah yeah i waited all [ __ ]
day it's a call you know this is when
you have no money right
you got to sit at the this is when
you're set to sit at starbucks
and [ __ ] take a sip every hour
you got to sit there and dehydrate
because god forbid you finish that
coffee yeah you got to milk that coffee
for 8 hours yeah you got to [ __ ]
steal a tuna sandwich from the hotel
before you leave and [ __ ] and now you
got to wait because you're going to have
enough money just to get the cab
the cab's 82 from the [ __ ]
because the the airport's never close to
the comedy club when you're broke it's
funny it's like being a drug addict
being a comedian it's like very similar
it's the same thing
you live the same way you live to to
just accommodate that right just to get
just to subsist you live you're gonna
get more of an idea of what the city is
than going on some guided tour you and i
just died like a [ __ ]
yeah people like this with gentlemen and
got shot in the head yeah if you guessed
it 100 percent
like that's what you know
this is where [ __ ] yo vaughn made
that drug deal yeah have dropped the cab
driving the chicken in the back this is
the real new york tio it's nothing
strawberry and [ __ ] this is the real
this is the real new york i used to you
know that's what i want to take this is
what the [ __ ] my friend louie got
heroin in the eighth grade yeah and
[ __ ] he puked and we left to me a
[ __ ] for dead
like it's it's that but that's what i
want to hear if i go to a city that's
what i want to hear
you know and i would tell you know what
i would do too because the apartments in
new york city is so expensive i try to
make everybody on the bus feel kind of
bad i just point it to buildings and i
go 10 million 20 million 30 million 35
40 million and everybody would just get
beaten down you know by the end of the
day they realize that they were [ __ ]
they were like god if the system's
rigged we're all shot you know and then
every now and then one of these fat
broads would try to like even the scale
should go but they don't even have
central air in those buildings they have
wall unit air conditioners and i go but
they do have central air in their
hamptons estates they take helicopters
and land in them because they don't want
to be at traffic many of them are 20 30
000 square feet and she would go
and it was basically me going like i
know you're trying to get one up on me
but not today pig not today and i would
just make them feel i want their spirits
broken by the time they left the bus i
wanted them to realize that they had
failed and there was nothing that they
could do [ __ ] that they [ __ ] up
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]